[Music]
our next speaker
is associate professor james schroer
from australia
he's the head of epidemiological
modelling unit at school of public
health at monash university
over to you james my name is james
trower
and i'm a respiratory and public health
physician
and i'm also head of epidemiological
modelling at the school of public health
and preventive medicine at monash
university
and i'm going to be talking about real
time modeling of a pandemic
and the challenges that has thrown up
this year clearly the pandemics had a
huge
impact on everybody's lives and the
economy and society as well as health
and it's been a huge challenge for
modelers as well it's been something
totally unprecedented from my point of
view
i've previously been a modeler that's
focused on tuberculosis being a
respiratory infection
and um it's a very different situation
the challenges of modeling a pandemic
mean that the ground is always
moving under you the moment you try to
simulate something the epidemic has
changed
and you're always chasing your tail
trying to understand what the data means
and by the time you've produced a
simulation uh it's often
out of date or the model needs to be
recalibrated the following week
so i'm going to talk about some of the
issues around
covert 19 and understanding its
epidemiology and transmission and how
we've tried to put that into models
and what that can tell us about the
future pathway of the epidemic
so to start off
i would like to introduce probably the
most widely used framework for
infectious disease modeling this is an
seir model um there's a lot a lot of
different things that can be referred to
as a model but when people talk about
mathematical modeling we're usually
talking about some sort of
mechanistic framework and i like the
word mechanistic because it
it conveys the fact that we're trying to
explicitly represent
the mechanism of disease transmission
that underlies what's happening in the
population
and so the seir framework represents um
the population as being in these
compartments
so each compartment is associated with
the number which is the number of people
in that state in relation to covert 19
and so the s compartment is the number
of people susceptible
the e compartment is the number of
people who have been exposed but haven't
yet developed symptoms
the eye compartment is the number of
people who are now symptomatic and also
infectious
and then as they transition into the r
compartment they recover or become
removed from the system and in this
framework they can't then be
infected again and so it's a pretty
simple system it's only
comprised of four compartments um and
if you think about the r naught of the
epidemic that's the number of people who
are infected by one infective person on
average in a fully susceptible
population
and this model does a pretty good job of
capturing some of the dynamics of that
early phase
of epidemic growth so in the
illustration on the left here you can
see that we have one person
infecting two people in the next
generation of infection infections
and then that progresses to four eight
sixteen and the model
if you just set it up as described in
that seir
framework uh you get that exponential
growth and the model does a pretty good
job of capturing that
uh you also get the general bell-shaped
curve of the epidemic and we've all seen
a lot of curves over recent years
sorry over recent months and
we've probably got a little bit bored of
looking at curves and being told to
flatten the curve
and and the curve itself if we think
about an epic
unmitigated epidemic and an epidemic in
which
nothing is done to control the virus
does look indeed a bit like a bell shape
that's what
we would predict from the models that's
what the sci framework can show us
and in reality if we had it done nothing
to control the epidemic we probably
would have got this very large bell
shape
so the model tells us a little bit about
that it tells us that the peak of the
bell is the point at which herd immunity
is reached and the downslope
after that peak is actually extra
infections that are not required to
reach herd immunity so we know that if
we were to let the epidemic play out
totally unmitigated we would actually
have far more infections than we would
need to prevent a
second wave and so people would not
necessarily
be infected and die and we it also tells
us that as we get towards
the tail that tail off
occurs because the number of
susceptibles in the population gradually
decreases it doesn't drop down to zero
but it gradually decreases
so this is the sort of framework that
was used prior to the pandemic by
organizations like the cdc to propose a
response but it was very much informed
by
the expected response that we would need
to have to influenza
given that so many new pandemics are
caused by influenza viruses so the plan
really for uh for an influenza pandemic
and responding to it was to mitigate the
epidemic just to flatten the curve
so uh this is certainly what flattening
the curve meant to me in march it seems
to mean something totally different now
but in in sort of the early months of
the year flattening the curve in
australia meant that we were
anticipating a very large bell-shaped
epidemic and we were going to try to
squash that down to a much
much flatter bell but still a pretty
substantial
epidemic we were never at that stage
trying
to totally eliminate or suppress the
epidemic
the idea was that if we could flatten
the curve to some extent we could keep
the number of
cases below what was what would have
overwhelmed our hospital capacity but
still allows substantial community
transmission
and that is essentially what happened in
the 2009 influenza pandemic we didn't
totally stamp it out probably somewhere
around 15
or a little under if the population were
infected by 2009 h1n1
influenza and uh
that may still happen i suppose in the
case of covert 19 but at this stage it
seems like a lot of countries are really
pushing towards uh well countries like
australia and new zealand are certainly
pushing towards having very low levels
of transmission and trying to keep
things such that a very small proportion
of the population
so in these early months of the year
models were
already informing policy and telling us
predicting what might happen
this was perhaps one of the most um
widely
cited and well recognized papers
that was led by neil ferguson from
imperial college it was an agent-based
simulation um which is a bit of a
different sort of a model it sort of
fits into the seo
framework to some extent but it
explicitly represents every individual
person within the population as an
individual
and explicitly says what they're doing
where they're going who they're
interacting with
and so this model received a lot of
criticism
after it was published because of the
way in which it was coded
and if you look at the outputs from it
it actually gives us
pretty similar outputs to what the scir
framework does it
basically just gives us a bell-shaped
curve so there's a range of
epidemiological models that are all
mechanistic
i guess that's the thing that they share
in common um
but they uh and they're all quite
different in terms of the engine
underneath the bonnet that is driving um
what how the epidemic plays out but
even these very sophisticated or
complicated um
epidemiological models that are based on
agents and individuals interacting still
give us this sort of general bell-shaped
curve which still captures those
fundamental aspects of an unmitigated
epidemic
and so this model was very influential
and its main conclusions i think
was still very sound in spite of the
criticism that it received in that
in that it did alert people to the huge
burden of infection that we might expect
if we did nothing to mitigate the co-19
epidemic
so these these bell-shaped curves tell
part of the story but the thing that
they don't
really tell as well as this
figure that also appeared in the same
paper is just
how enormous the epidemic would have
been have we done nothing from the
outset
because that horizontal red line towards
the bottom of this graph
is the surge critical care capacity so
that's that's additional
resources put in place in the uk or the
us to
allow for additional people to be
admitted to icu on top of what
is normally available and the you can
see just how enormously the
curves smash through that threshold
in the case of a mitigated epidemic but
even in the case of a mitigated epidemic
which is something like the orange curve
where we have
restrictions in place for a certain
period of time in that gray area but
then we release those restrictions and
try
to just get by with case up isolation
and um some milder social distancing
mechan
interventions that is still uh it's a
flatter curve but and
flattening the curve you know i suppose
helps to some extent but it still is
way way way over what um our surge
critical care bed capacity
would be expected to be so um
that was i think very informative very
useful and
was very influential and um that
was useful information to have early in
the epidemic and sort of
was uh incorporated with the fact that
we were observing very high rates of
uh disease and icu occupancy in
countries like italy and we did see
a major catastrophe there in the early
months of the year so
so it became clear that those general
messages from the model were correct and
that the covert 19 epidemic was going to
have a massive effect
um we did we put together a
short paper that's available in med
archive
that does a similar sort of thing to
what was proposed
in that agent-based simulation by the
ferguson group
and imperial college but does just use
an scir framework and so it was
essentially just a compartmental model
and a deterministic model not simulating
individuals
as ferguson's group did so essentially
it's seir
really the we've split a couple of
compartments into two
um for reasons i won't go into but the
the
really the only thing that we wanted to
add on to this was just an
additional compartment just to simulate
people in
intensive care units to explicitly be
able to estimate
the number of people who would be
admitted to icu
over time if we had a major epidemic in
australia
in the top panel here we have a totally
unmitigated epidemic to the left so this
is if
our naught or they are effective or
reproduction number
remains well above two we would see this
huge epidemic that overwhelms critical
capacity with that horizontal dotted
blue line being the
critical capacity if we did
some sort of moderate measures you can
see again that we flattened the curve to
some extent that's the second curve in
the top panel
but the number of people in icu still
massively overwhelms even our surge
critical care
capacity if we try to
knock the reproduction number down even
further to perhaps 1.2
we can keep numbers down to within
critical care bed capacity
but you can see that the epidemic plays
out then for a much
longer period of time and it's perhaps
mid 2022
before the epidemic is over by which
time we might hope to have a vaccine
so so that shows the idea of this is to
illustrate that
the idea of partially mitigating a major
outbreak
in the case of covert 19 was much more
problematic than what
might have been anticipated for an
influenza pandemic just because the
the number of people requiring icu and
the severity of the disease was much
greater for
in the case of covert 19 in the lower
panel there we have what happens if you
just go that little bit further and
right rather than reduce the
reproduction number to 1.2 that you try
to just knock it down somewhere below
one and so if you try to keep it at 0.8
for example
you basically don't have an epidemic the
blue line is then right at the top of
the graph and the number of people
getting infected is right down at the
bottom and so you have very few
uh very limited transmission and you
don't have to worry about critical care
capacity at all
so the message here was that if you're
going to put in place a lot of very
major
interventions to try to knock the
epidemic down from a reproduction number
of 2.4 to 1.2 you might as well
put a couple of extra ones in place and
try to get down to 0.8 and a lot of
countries are trying to do that
such as australia and new zealand
although some countries just don't
have the resources or the opportunity to
be able to do that
the flip side of it though is that we
don't get close to reaching herd
immunity if we take
this pathway so if we think about the
unmitigated epidemic that's the solid
black line
and the green horizontal bar is the herd
immunity threshold
and the vertical axis is the proportion
or the number of people in australia who
are still susceptible to
the epidemic after the first wave so if
we were to have let a huge unmitigated
epidemic occur
as i mentioned we would go past the herd
immunity threshold and more people would
be infected
than is necessary if we get down to that
point of
just carefully trying to find our way to
the herd immunity threshold within our
effective
reproduction number of 1.2 we would
have a very large epidemic as we saw
we'd still overwhelm critical care
capacity
and um and that's the dashed line
if we try to keep things under enough
control to
stay within critical care capacity
that's the dotted line and we're still
nowhere near the herd immunity threshold
whereas if we go through this
intermittent
strategy of trying to keep the epidemic
suppressed and keep the reproduction of
the very
low numbers below one we're not very low
numbers but just somewhere below one
we basically end up with the entire
population remaining fully susceptible
to the epidemic so that means that we
still have the potential
for explosive outbreaks if we release
the brakes on the system and the
reproduction number pops back up above
one so unfortunately this illustrates
that no
strategy is perfect and
any pathway that we choose has a lot of
problems until we have
a vaccine that can um that can provide
us with a
technologically based solution uh
but uh i think it's really important to
understand
things in this context and that the herd
immunity threshold as much as it's
become a bit of a dirty term
is a really important concept for
understanding what's going on in the
background of the epidemic
so why is covert 19 so hard to control
and why is it like this and why haven't
we been able to do what we did with sars
for example in 2003
and control it and why is it also so
different from influenza well i've
already discussed the fact that it's
more severe than influenza
in the case of influenza there were a
series of epidemics of course we tend to
get them every 10 to 20 years
the last really major one was in 1918 so
this graph is from that same document
from the cdc
that plots each of the epidemics
according to their severity and their
transmissibility and infectiousness um
so that if you're in the top right in
that black area you're a
particularly nasty pandemic and if
you're in the bottom left
you're perhaps a bit milder or
more controllable epidemic and you can
see that gradually
over time through the course of the 20th
century and beyond
the pandemic seemed to get a little bit
milder on the whole so the 1918 one was
a disaster but nobody remembers that now
because it's
too long ago for anybody to be able to
tell us about so we just have to read
about it
um and then as the 20th century evolved
and played out the epidemic seemed to
march from that top right down to the
bottom left not consistently and this is
a totally
random thing of course but i think it
just illustrates
how the epidemics and the history of the
pandemics
perhaps load us into a bit of a false
sense of security the ones that we were
able to remember better were the
milder more controllable ones and so we
weren't as prepared as we might be for a
very major
very uh transmissible and very severe
so to understand a little bit about why
19 might be particularly difficult to
control i just want to talk about
the patient's journey through the course
of infection disease
and this is a brief timeline you can
think that at the start of the blue
box there that somebody's been infected
sometimes after that they become
infectious then they might develop
symptoms
they've been detected by uh medical
system and some
time after that they would hopefully be
isolated and
perhaps even later than that they would
they might be notified
to the public health system and their
data might work through the surveillance
system so that we
so they appear in the numbers that we
see every day
um there's some quantities that we talk
about in epidemiological modeling called
the serial interval and the generation
time so if you think about the
person who the index case is that top
line and then the person who they infect
is the bottom line
the generation time is the interval
between one person being infected
getting infected um and the serial
interval is the
time between that first person
developing symptoms and the person they
infected
so this these principles were what
a paper that was published in nature
medicine that looked at data from
a hospital in southern china two
different data sets
this is one of the data sets in which
you can see the exposure window between
two people one who was the index case
who did the infecting and one who was
the secondary case
if you look at the delay between the red
dot and the blue dot
you you can get a sense for when the
primary case had their symptom onset in
the secondary case
got their symptoms and how that relates
to the
window exposure and so that allowed
these
so they they had information basically
on the serial interval
the interval between one person eating
symptoms and their their infected
contact getting symptoms
and they could say when those people
would come into contact
so that gave them enough information to
be able to reconstruct some information
about the infectiousness profiles of
the individual with code the other
piece of information or the other data
set that they had available was what's
called a cycle time which is um
the higher the number the the more virus
somebody is producing i suppose is the
easiest way to think about
it and people had this information
available
from the point of symptom onset onward
and so we could see
that as cycle time went up in number and
that line goes down
the uh as time goes along that quantity
sort of reduces so what we're saying is
that people are getting less infectious
over time from developing symptoms and
the
thing that they really wanted to
emphasize here was that right from the
very start from day zero that
line already appears to be sloping
downwards and the data's a bit noisy but
what they're saying
is that even at the point at which we
start observing people with symptoms
their infectious infectiousness already
seems to be decreasing
and so what that suggests is that the p
came before
their symptoms started and so combined
with that data on the serial interval
we can we can reconstruct some sort of
picture
of how infectiousness plays out relative
and these were some other figures from
this paper and in the top right we have
a sort of a i guess this doesn't come
from data but it's an
illustration of what we think was going
on with sars in 2003 that the primary
case has a period of time
in which they're asymptomatic that's the
blue boxes on the left
and then they develop symptoms as they
enter the purple boxes towards the right
in case of sars we generally thought
that
most of the infectiousness which are the
blue most bell-shaped curves
infectiousness occurred after symptoms
commenced so it meant that public health
interventions had the potential to be
a lot more effective by identifying
people
after they had symptoms and isolating
them promptly you could cut out most of
their transmission
um that's to some extent similar to
seasonal influenza in the bottom right
although there's probably some
transmission that occurs
prior to symptoms starting but these
researchers were able to
present data that suggests that in the
case of covert we might have
something that's a little bit more along
the lines of the panels on the left
so for example in the top panel there we
have the bell-shaped
blue curve having a substantial
proportion of its
mass to the left of symptom onset so a
lot of people are getting
infectious before they have symptoms
which makes it very difficult to
identify these people in time to isolate
them and stop them from
infection so the third thing i'd like to
talk about and probably the last thing
is
is thinking about data and trying to
quantify the covert epidemic which you
would think would be
very easy given how many people have had
um covert and how the internet is making
data very accessible
people and people a lot of people
watching websites like the johns hopkins
website
but if we look at cases or notifications
actually
they don't really tell the whole story
they tell a lot of the story in some
countries like towards the bottom of the
graph here we have that in australia
we've had very high testing capacity
and this is the this is the estimated
proportion of symptomatic cases that we
think
are detected in australia we think most
symptomatic cases
have been detected since pretty early in
the epidemic
and that's been very variable but but a
lot of countries have done well
uh such as malaysia and australia in
but in contrast in the top part of the
panel there are a lot of countries that
particularly for ambulatory patients who
have not admitted to hospital there just
was very very little testing capacity
and
and in a sense for some of these
countries testing was not really a major
component of their response so for
example in the uk and france the
proportion
of um people who were not admitted to
hospital who
received the test and were effectively
diagnosed was very very small
which has implications for whether those
people couldn't be isolated of course
um and so it has implications from the
perspective of the public health
response but it also
has implications in terms of
understanding the epidemic in these
countries
so for example in france we really
have to use modeling to give us a sense
for how big the epidemic
is and those models um
this is an example of a model that was
produced by simon koshmas group
published in science which was a very
major and influential
piece that aimed to give a sense of the
epidemic in france it
did as good a job as it could it was
fitted to
the data that were available that
included things like hospital admissions
and general ward beds
um being used and um and made some use
of notification data
but there were a fair few assumptions
that needed to be fed into this model
such as the infection fatality rate
which i'll talk about a little bit later
um and so i guess what the model in the
sense is doing here is that it's
compensating for the fact that we don't
really have a good sense from
surveillance data about what the size of
the epidemic was in france
so the so the model was needed to
reconstruct that
and there's things like the proportion
of people infected
using surveillance data because such a
small proportion of people were actually
identified
is not a satisfactory way to work that
out and so the model
can give us a sense for that cro surveys
are an even better way probably of
working that out
um but for example in panel e you can
see that they estimated that even
after this major um major epidemic
only around four percent or or
six to seven at most of the population
had been infected
so so some of the most important
quantities think about uh
or yeah other infection fatality rate
the case fatality rate is something
that's discussed a lot and it's
important to understand the difference
between these two things so the case
fatality rate is the
number of deaths divided by the number
of cases
that are identified so so if you look at
the
daily notifications for some of these
countries that's the denominator in the
case of the case fatality rate
but as we've just discussed it's
extremely dependent upon
the um the testing capacity
because in some countries they're just
not the denominator is really very
unknown
um or might be very small compared to
the number of infections that have
occurred
and so that inflates the case fatality
rate so what we're really more
interested in as epidemiological
modelers or epidemiologists is the
infection fatality
rate which we think is a little bit more
consistent between countries regardless
of testing capacity
and that's defined defined as the
proportion
of infections that result in deaths so
the number of coca-19 deaths divided by
the number of infections
and that's a a quantity that we're more
interested in but then it's also
a little bit more difficult to identify
because we don't necessarily know how
many infections
occurred in a population so even models
like
the one that i presented from single
question
have limitations and they have to make
assumptions about things like the
infection
so the infection fatality rate in papers
like this and other ones
are estimated from small groups of
patients who
are very well described so an example is
the diamond princess which is a cruise
ship
that people probably have heard of that
docked in
japan and had a major outbreak and just
about everybody on the cruise ship
was tested and so we know
size of that outbreak pretty well and it
was a
it was an outbreak that had your
particular characteristics of its own
um which i won't go into but it's
assumed that we can
estimate the infection fatality rate
because we
because in this case it was possible to
identify all of the infections
so we think there were 712 infections on
the diamond princess
and we um and we have some sense of the
number of deaths that occurred although
even for that there are still some uh
people who are in
long-term icu who um uh
well at the time of publication the
kosher movie paper they were but
even even determining the number of
deaths there are some issues but we can
have a pretty good idea
so there were 14 deaths and and four
people admitted to long-term icu so
somewhere between 14 and 18
deaths among 712 people
and though they were distributed very um
very much towards the older age groups
and so
papers like this or studies like this
have been what has been used to estimate
the infection fatality rate which we
know is of course very very different
according to age group
um but i think so the reason that i've
described this is because it just
highlights how
in spite of the number of deaths and the
number of cases that have occurred
to work out the infection fatality rate
we're still going back to
relatively small groups of people who
have been well described to
calculate these critical quantities for
our models
and perhaps the only other way to think
about
um the impact of coca-19 is to look at
all-cause mortality which is
a really useful thing to do and we can
see that it's spiked up in just about
all countries across the world since the
start of the pandemic
um to a very major extent and
um so you can see the ones that are
identified
as having been covered 19 deaths here
illustrated in orange
and that sits on top of a sort of a gray
background underneath
that gives more of a sense of the
all-cause mortality
and for the particular time of the year
the dashed line is what you would expect
for each of these countries
and so you can see again how the how the
infection the number of deaths
mortality or cause mortality rate has
really risen up very markedly above that
um and so in a lot of cases that's to a
greater extent than the orange
area would it would suggest so that even
some deaths that are not attributable
not attributable or haven't been
attributed to copen 19
are probably a consequence
that's something that's really um
important and good to do
in countries that have good vital
registration systems and good
records of deaths but actually that's
not
always the case and a surprising number
of countries around around the world and
a lot of low and middle income countries
do not have
high quality vital registration systems
so getting a sense of what's going on in
low and middle income countries is
difficult
um even in countries that have
some data such as jakarta where there's
monthly information
on variables we do still see a similar
pattern so it does seem that
um the extent of the pandemic in lower
middle income countries
is probably greater than was previously
the
well probably greater than is recognized
from surveillance statistics
so in this example in jakarta you can
see that in march and april of this year
there were considerably more
deaths overalls considerably more
burials occurring even though a very
small portion of that additional number
was attributed
to cobra 19. so we think that there was
probably quite substantial transmission
going on under the surface
so i will finish up there but just
quickly to recap and i've left a few
slides out at the end
um but happy to discuss other issues in
the
discussion forum later over 19 has
presented huge new challenges for our
models
even constructing models that capture
the epidemic by the time
you've published them or even
constructed them a month or a few weeks
later
you might be in the middle of the second
wave and you have to really really
totally rethink about what your
model needs to look like modeling has
been undertaken at breathtaking
breathtaking speed it has given some
really important
messages that have influenced policy in
the early phases of the epidemic and
many of them
inspired the critic despite the
criticism were broadly correct
and even the simplest models can provide
insights into the current situation and
how we should be responding to it
and despite the number of cases reported
the data that we're using to inform our
models remains imperfect
thanks so much for your time
thank you associate professor james
schroer for a great presentation